we are transferring power from
Washington DC and giving it back to you
the people we are going to Washington DC
and we are going to drain the swamp this
story that we saw throughout the
campaign is that this town in particular
has failed America's Washington DC
washington DC washington DC washington
flourished but the people did not share
ninety-six percent of the DC population
did not vote for president Trump so DC's
kind of an anomaly versus the rest of
the country where it isn't necessarily
as receptive to our incoming president I
have reservations about his ability to
make it four years in this city in fact
in my office we've been taken vestige
might make it two years before he does
something so egregious that either gets
run out of town or decides to resign out
of embarrassment I would assume he's
gonna have a hard time for the next four
years especially since a lot of people
in DC work for government and work for
congressmen and Congresswomen I think
that either gonna have some real
challenging time to say that everyone
here is just affiliated with the
government or that you know we're some
sort of swamp or federal elitist need to
be drained it yeah it's not exactly
we're not exactly welcoming I guess
we'll terms of wanting him to be in our
neighborhood not setting good
neighbourly vibe we are going to drain
the swamp the problem is when you take
on the swab the people in the stuff they
don't like to see the SWAT drain so
there's going to be a lot of opposition
or resistance as he believes Washington
has become too big and too influential I
guarantee you the lobbyists are lined up
right now trying to devise strategies to
stop Donald Trump the establishment
protected itself but not the citizens of
our country oh i think there's always
resistance but you know i think that
he's making a new establishment that
speaks to the concerns of the working
men and women of this country and i'm
confident that that's going to be a
leadership position that many of the
members of the so-called establish what
we will be following instead of
resisting you don't know what to expect
and i think people are kind of on the
edge of their seats washington DC
washington DC washington DC